25 años después del acuerdo de paz del
viernes Santo un muro de 5 km de largo
sigue dividiendo las zonas obreras de
belfast donde estalló el conflicto que
mató a más de 3.500 personas en tres
décadas de un lado se encuentran los
católicos quienes están a favor de la
unificación de Irlanda y del lado
opuesto los protestantes que se
mantienen fieles a la corona británica
estamos en el lado lealista del muro
mi hogar político y cultural está al
otro lado
Connor mas que trabaja para reconciliar
las dos comunidades pero procede de una
familia republicana militante
hace 25 años jamás habría soñado con
conducir por aquí ahora como puede ver
es un lugar turístico
incluso hay antiguos prisioneros
lealistas y republicanos que guían a los
turistas y les enseñan Este muro
el viernes santo de la semana pasada
personas de ambos lados del muro unieron
sus manos en la intersección de sus
barrios para celebrar los acuerdos de
paz Uno de ellos es un antiguo dirigente
del ira
iceberg pasé 12 años en la cárcel como
miembro de Lira
ahora soy guía turístico
hemos dado algunos pasos hacia adelante
y otros hacia atrás pero si comparamos
nuestra sociedad con la de hace 25 años
hemos avanzado mucho
este es el único parque de Europa
atravesado por un muro durante el
conflicto esta zona era conocida como
los campos de Exterminio
[Música]
ahora la violencia política casi ha
terminado como concejal local con normas
que ayuda a los habitantes del lado
protestante con la esperanza de ver
desaparecer pronto estos muros Ojalá
pudiera ser mañana pero para ello
primero hay que desarmar el miedo en la
mente de la gente es psicológico más
emocional que físico
orgullosamente Leal a la corona el
barrio de Newton arts Road nunca ha sido
acogedor para los católicos los
paramilitares realistas marcan su
territorio pero sus armas guardan
silencio también aquí el progreso es
visible esta cervecería es un lugar de
encuentro para los que estudian la
lengua irlandesa el gaélico entre ellos
se encuentra esta pareja de protestantes
estoy aprendiendo Irlandés porque me
hacía falta en mi cultura ya que soy de
origen unionista no tuvimos la
oportunidad de aprender Irlandés en la
escuela el proyecto turas se ha hecho
popular cuenta ahora con 500 alumnos
antes del acuerdo era impensable cuando
lindavin empezó hace 10 años recibía
amenazas de muerte
por ser de este barrio me consideran
fuera de lugar
a la gente no le gusta
la mayoría de las personas de aquí son
racionales y razonables
Pero hay algunas
que se sienten amenazadas por lo que
hago en casa de los más que se hacen las
tareas de gaelí en familia cocra
significa morado a este lado del muro es
costumbre aprender el Irlandés en el
acuerdo de paz se fundamenta el respeto
mutuo por las dos grandes tradiciones
culturales hace 30 años los tíos de
Connor se unieron al ira él tenía 20
años en el momento del acuerdo su vida
cambió habría tenido que elegir si el
conflicto hubiera continuado me habría
Unido al conflicto armado
no se trata de una elección natural para
mí
y doy gracias a Dios por no haber tenido
que elegir
[Aplausos]
esta es tu abuelo y este es tu papá
estaban en la policía
Nataly Andrew tenían 10 años cuando se
firmó el acuerdo sus padres eran
policías objetivos potenciales del ira
Hasta que el ejército clandestino
renunció a la violencia y dejó las armas
me ponía nervioso cuando la gente me
preguntaba A qué se dedicaba mi padre
siempre decía que era funcionario
recuerdo que no podía subir directamente
al coche había que esperar a que papá y
mamá lo revisaran
Supongo que como Mi padre estaba en el r
uc subía corría peligro el Antiguo ruc
era protestante en un 93%, la reforma de
la policía fue también uno de los puntos
centrales del acuerdo el nuevo servicio
de policía cuenta con el apoyo de la
gran mayoría
el acuerdo del viernes Santo ha cambiado
realmente la esencia a nuestro país
se necesitaba una nueva policía para un
nuevo país fueron
uno de los protagonistas del conflicto
Ahora son un servicio público
transparente
el consejo municipal de belfas se
comparte el poder
pero desde hace un año el principal
partido unionista bloquea la instalación
del gobierno regional debido a los
términos del brexit que crean una
frontera comercial entre Reino Unido e
Irlanda del Norte
esta frontera en el mar de Irlanda está
fracturando en nuestro país Así es como
lo vemos ningún otro país aceptaría esto
según los últimos sondeos la inmensa
mayoría de los norierlandeses desea El
regreso inmediato de un gobierno en el
que representantes electos de ambas
tradiciones compartan el poder tal y
como prevén los acuerdos de paz